Officials from both Emory Healthcare and
the Hawks hosted the Grand Opening of
the Emory Sports Medicine Complex
RESSLER: "This partnership between Emory Healthcare and the Atlanta Hawks will
be great for our franchise, hopefully
great for Emory,
but most importantly great for the
community."
It was only 18 months ago that Tony, Steve, Bud, and I
had the pleasure of announcing
our partnership and plans to
reimagine what true integration looks
like between a professional sports
franchise and a major academic health
care system. Our physicians, therapists,
and trainers will work with the elite
professionals and weekend warriors from
all sports in the same facilities, and
our slogan, that you'll read when you take
the tour, 'Go where the players go,'
will never have been more true."
BODEN: "This is the main patient lobby."
Dr. Scott Boden, Director of Emory's
Orthopaedic and Spine Center, kicked off
the press tour of the new facility.
One of the first stops was Peak Performance Project,
a sports training and evaluation service area
more commonly called P3.
P3 is a world leader in athlete
performance measurement and sports
science. This P3 headquarters is one of
only two such facilities in the country.
BODEN: "So there's room for seven physician
teams to be seeing patients.
The physicians move this way in this space
and the patients move across." In addition
to the latest state-of-the-art medical equipment,
the patient care space is designed
to enhance efficiency and
collaboration between the different
clinicians who will be working here.
BODEN: "This facility and the broader Sports Medicine
Program it supports will allow us to
continue to recruit and retain the best
talent in physicians, nurses, therapists, trainers,
and all their support staff.
HAWKS STAFF:  "This is where basically
every practice day starts..."
Housed in the same building
will be the Hawks' training and
administrative headquarters.
HAWKS STAFF:  "The next major free agent that Travis
signs he's going to sign in that room."
Everything from the room where
draft picks will be evaluated
to a gourmet kitchen
were on display.
HAWKS STAFF: "We try to communicate
good healthy eating habits."
Torian Prince, the Hawke's forward, showed us around
the team's locker room and spa.
PRINCE: "From the courts to the training room to the
kitchen to the smoothie area to the
locker room his first class... and as
players we're definitely appreciative and
we don't take it for granted.
But perhaps the most impressive spectacle was the
massive world-class practice court where
Atlanta's pro basketball team will hone their skills.
BUDENHOLZER: "When you have a facility
like this, it just takes player
development to a whole other level.